pero los talibanes anunciaron este lunes
haber tomado el control completo del
valle de panshir último bastión de la
oposición tras la toma de kabul el
pasado 15 de agosto en la capital de la
provincia de panshir está bajo control
de los muyaidines el enemigo sufrió
muchos daños sufre los muyahidines no
sufrirán ningún daño después de dos días
el gobierno de la provincia de panshir
está bajo el control del emirato
islámico de afganistán
imágenes muestran a los talibanes usando
una bandera en la capital pero la
situación en terreno es incierta pues la
lucha paso de las armas a las palabras y
ambos grupos disputan mediáticamente el
dominio del territorio el frente
nacional de resistencia rechaza las
afirmaciones del grupo talibán y niega
en twitter haber perdido el último
territorio bajo su dominio la afirmación
de los talibanes de haber ocupado
banchile es falsa la fuerza del frente
nacional de resistencia están presentes
en todas las posiciones estratégicas del
valle para continuar la lucha le
aseguramos al pueblo de afganistán que
la lucha contra los talibanes y sus
socios continuará hasta que prevalezca
la justicia y la libertad por el momento
saber lo que realmente pasa en el
terreno es casi imposible ya que es poca
la información que entra y sale de este
valle encerrado entre montañas